so I've recently discovered a mistake
FUNimation made that I don't think
anyone else has noticed online this past
week I have dedicated my entire life to
diving deep into the FUNimation dub of
Dragon Ball Z and looking at all the
changes that were made from when it
aired on TV to when you eventually got
it on DVD Blu-ray and streaming at home
and while there was such an insane
amount of stuff I found that I ended up
having to make a whole video on YouTube
to cover it all there was one in
particular that really just slayed me
it's this scene where Piccolo is
fighting Cell for the very first time in
the original dub as it aired on TV
Piccolo says this line well now you've
got it
you're not as dumb
EST pretty normal right nothing really
of note but then let's take a look at
what the line was replaced with for your
home release
now you've got it
just you're not as dumb as I am dumb as
I am dumb as I am dumb as I am